god of war is the latest sony title to
be getting a pc port so we'll be
comparing it to its console counterpart
for the playstation version we are
running it on a ps5 with the upgraded
enhanced performance patch that runs the
game at 60fps with a 4k checkerboard
resolution meanwhile we have the pc
version running on maxed out ultra
settings at a native 4k resolution the
pc version does offer a small but decent
number of improvements such as increased
texture quality and dynamic fog to name
a few however these can be pretty subtle
once you actually start to compare the
two side by side after all god of war
was designed from the ground up to be a
console game only so don't expect the
visuals to have this major leap on the
pc that said the most dramatic and
obvious difference is in the shadows
which can change scenes quite
dramatically you will also notice in
this comparison a difference in color
however that has more to do with how
these games were captured on different
devices and is not indicative of any
real difference between the two versions
okay enjoy the comparison and remember
to give us a thumbs up if you like this
video and subscribe to gamespot for more
coverage on all things video games
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so
[Music]
that is enough
father what
did something change
the forest feels
different
everything is different boy
try not to dwell on it
yes sir
this way boy
[Music]
oh
wait dear tracks they're fresh
this way
[Music]
found it
slow down boy
sorry
there it is hold
are you doing now as guard is up
only fire
[Music]
holy fire
when i tell you to fire
i'm sorry
do not be sorry
be
better
find it
[Music]
find
it
no
you are not ready stay back
[ __ ]
huh
[Music]
your knife
no
finish what you started
[Music]
i can't
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
think i'm afraid
look at me look at me boy
boy
look at
[Music]
me did it
[Music]
you are not ready
what
are you serious
i found the deer
i proved myself
how am i not ready we are going home
[Music]
i haven't been sick in a long time
i can do this
you are not ready
[Music]
you